Guten Morgen, Thomas.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, willst du noch ein paar Chips?
Danke, hier gibt es ja schon genug.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 515 vom 26.
Februar 2025. 25, aber aus einer ungewohnten Zeitzone, denn wir sind da,
wo es ganz viele Chips gibt.
In Taiwan.
Hattest du schon ein paar.
Ganz ganz viele.
Ja, wir sind in Taiwan, auf einer wunderschönen Insel mit ganz freundlichen
Menschen und wir werden nachher gleich noch mehr über das Land sagen und wieso wir hier sind.
Aber ja, es ist schon irgendwie ein Zukunftsort, oder Tim?
Ein Zukunftsort?
Ich finde schon.
Ja, da ist was dran und es ist auch ein Gegenwartsort.
Warum sind wir hier? Wir sind hier wegen der Ridescon-Konferenz.
Und das hat uns hier beide zeitgleich, zwangsläufig, hierher geführt.
Und da werden wir dann gleich drüber berichten.
Aber bevor wir das machen, müssen wir noch Entwarnung geben,
denn es gibt eine gute Nachricht.
Denn der Weltuntergang wurde abgewendet.
Vorderfick.
Naja, also ich meine, Ende letzten Jahres war ja alle noch so voll im Doomsday-Modus
mit irgendwie, oh Gott, was kommt jetzt auf uns zu und man weiß es ja nicht
und das kann ja bald alles zu Ende sein.
Stellt sich raus, gibt nur eine,
0,001 7%ige Chance auf Weltuntergang weil der Meteorit YR4 wird jetzt doch nicht
die Erde treffen, wie es noch gedacht wurde.
Wobei genau genommen ist es ja noch gar kein Meteorit, es ist ja ein Asteroid.
Gibt es einen Unterschied?
Ne, das habe ich mich immer gefragt.
Naja, also es handelt sich, also es gibt sozusagen Asteroiden,
Meteore und Meteoriten.
Ein Asteroid ist ein Stück Stein, was durchs Weltall fliegt.
Ein Meteor ist ein Stück Stein, was durchs Weltall geflogen ist und dann in
die Atmosphäre eintritt, der Erde, und dort diesen Meteorstreifen macht und
dann knien alle nieder und begrüßen den neuen Heiland.
Und wenn das Ding dann runtergekommen ist und irgendwie in der Erde steckt,
das was übrig bleibt, ist ein Meteorit.
Ah, okay.
Also es handelt sich mehr oder weniger eigentlich um dasselbe Ding,
nur in unterschiedlichen Momenten.
Es hat nichts damit zu tun, ob das aus Stein oder Wasser besteht.
Das heißt jetzt dieser Asteroid YR4, der wird es nicht zum Meteoriten schaffen
oder nur noch mit einer 0,0017%igen wahrscheinlich.
So sieht es derzeit aus. Genau, der wird jetzt demnächst dann wieder aus unserem
Blick verschwinden. und dann müssen wir nochmal ein paar Jahre warten bis 2028
glaube ich, dann sehen wir ihn wieder und dann kann man nochmal gucken,
ob die Berechnungen auch gestimmt haben, aber sind jetzt eigentlich relativ entspannt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich auf diese Wahrscheinlichkeit verlassen will.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja eh kein planetarer Killer, oder?
Also da würde was übrig bleiben von der Erde.
Ja, ja, ja, das ist eher so die Kategorie Chelyabinsk. Also der Meteor,
der unangekündigt, weil man den vorher nicht gesehen hat, 2013 in Russland runtergekommen ist.
Das ist so eine halbe Megatonne TNT-Sprengkraft.
Der hat ja schon ganz ordentlich Wumms gemacht. Ich weiß nicht,
ob du es noch in Erinnerung hast.
Da gab es dann, weil das in Russland war, gab es natürlich dann ganz viele Dashcam-Aufnahmen
und da ist also der Ort amtlich entglast worden und wird irgendwelche Personenschäden
gegeben, man weiß jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau,
aber es war im Wesentlichen so ein helles Licht,
Kabumm, also dieser Eintritt in die Atmosphäre mit so viel Energie,
mit so viel kinetischer Energie, das macht dann schon was.
Und der ist dann aber irgendwo im Sumpf runtergekommen und man hat dann später
auch Meteoriten gefunden, also unterschiedliche Abspaltungen davon.
Und das ist jetzt nicht so schön, also das will man jetzt nicht in so einem
urbanen Zentrum irgendwie haben, wobei YR4 würde irgendwo am Äquator einschlagen,
also können wir das eigentlich auch ignorieren.
Ja, na, ich weiß nicht, ob wir sie ignorieren können, aber es ist eine gute
Nachricht und die sind gerade sowieso sehr heiß begehrt.
Genau, sehr heiß begehrt war auch natürlich das Feedback zur letzten Sendung.
Wir wollen ja jetzt nicht auf alles eingehen, weil das werde ich dann sicherlich
nochmal mit Linus aufgreifen.
Aber du als Österreicher bist ja betroffen von unserer Diskussion rund um Fucking.
Sehr betroffen.
Ja, also Fucking ist ja umbenannt worden oder hat sich umbenannt und dazu gab
es dann auf jeden Fall auch noch Kommentare, zum Beispiel von Klaus.
Er schreibt, Moin, die von euch referenzierte Umbenennung des Ortes,
ich muss Fucking sagen, des Ortes Fucking in Österreich ist dramatisch.
Früher konnte man die wirklich wichtige Frage, wie lange es dauert,
um vom Petting zu Fucking zu kommen, an Google Maps stellen.
Und wir haben das rausgesucht, es geht so grob um 30 Minuten.
30 Minuten, gut. Also ist das ja eigentlich auch geklärt. Genau.
Markus T. schreibt da noch, und in Petting habe ich trotz mehrfachen Aufenthalts
nie ein Ortsschild gesehen. Immer nur die Halterung.
Warum nur? Tja, das müssen wir offen lassen.
Ja, es ist schade. Also ich fand auch Fucking, da gibt es sogar,
glaube ich, eine eigene Serie in Österreich dazu. Oder gab es mal.
Ach echt?
Und dass die sich umbenannt haben, war schon wirklich ein kultureller Verlust.
Aber angeblich war das auch so etwas mit, die Kinder werden so gleich irgendwie
ganz, ganz mit schlechten Sachen konfrontiert.
Und jetzt nennen wir es einfach Fugging, weil so haben wir es eh immer schon ausgesprochen.
Die Kinder gäbe es gar nicht ohne Fugging.
Muss man ja auch mal feststellen.
Ja, aber diese von Linus in der letzten Sendung erwähnte Bier,
das Fucking Hell-Bier, das war einfach auch nur ein geiler Markenhack,
weil du kannst ja zu jedem Ort, wenn du dort ein helles Bier braust,
es hell nennen.
Klar.
Und das war einfach wirklich nur eins und eins zusammengezählt.
Ein absoluter Glücksgriff und so gut platziert, dass wir es jetzt schon zweimal hier erwähnt haben.
Ja, Shit, gratis Werbung.
Das ist ja wirklich ein totaler Werbepodcast geworden.
Na gut, kommen wir zu Taiwan. Vielleicht bevor wir über die Konferenz reden,
sollten wir vielleicht mal so ein bisschen was zu dem Ort sagen.
Bin mir nicht so richtig sicher. Also mir war ja die Bedeutung von Taiwan schon bewusst.
Ich habe aber immer wieder gemerkt in Gesprächen, nicht hier,
aber zu Hause, dass das nicht unbedingt jeder so geht.
Also für viele ist das so, ja, irgendeine Insel und warum wird denn da überhaupt drüber geredet?
Und dabei gibt es ein paar interessante Dinge.
Also erstmal ist natürlich Taiwan in der Geschichte ein wichtiger Player gewesen
rund um den Zweiten Weltkrieg herum.
Und jetzt hier einen kompletten geschichtlichen Abriss liefern zu wollen,
sollte man aber so ein bisschen verstehen,
dass das eben sehr eng verbunden war mit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg insofern,
als zu dem Zeitpunkt der Führer der Chinesischen Republik,
Chiang Kai-shek, der hat halt die Japaner quasi ferngehalten,
die ja auch in China angegriffen haben, Weltkrieg war ja wirklich fast überall
und von daher so ein bisschen auch ein natürlicher Verbündeter der USA in dem Fall,
die ja dann auch die Japaner bekämpft haben,
dann letztlich ja auch die Niederlage der Japaner erzwungen haben durch ihre
Atombomben, Abwürfe und generell ihre militärische Überlegenheit,
die sie dann entwickelt haben.
Und Chiang Kai-shek war halt auch deshalb dann den Amerikanern nahe,
weil er dann auch gegen die Maoisten die kommunistische Revolution in China
wenn dann auch letztlich nicht erfolgreich aber zumindest gekämpft hat diese
Republik China also die Vertreter,
dieser Bewegung in China, die sich dann eben nicht militärisch durchsetzen konnte,
sind dann nach Taiwan geflohen und deswegen gibt es halt die Republik China jetzt in Taiwan,
während eben die Volksrepublik China auf dem Mainland ist und in den letzten Jahren,
Haben wir ja nun immer wieder gehört, wie sehr die Volksrepublik China danach
strebt, sich nun auch noch diese Insel einzuverleiben, so wie sie es jetzt eben
auch mit den ganzen Kolonien gemacht hat.
Also natürlich nicht militärisch, sondern eben durch die Übergabe von Makao und Hongkong.
Und dass eben hier auch so ein potenzieller Konflikt ist, wo sich alle fragen,
wird China Taiwan angreifen oder wird das nicht passieren? Und je nachdem,
wen du so fragst, ist es halt so oder so.
Letztlich war aber dieser Chiang Kai-Shek hier auch eine sehr umstrittene Führungspersönlichkeit,
denn er hat dann doch auf eine extrem autoritäre Herrschaft umgeschwenkt und
es gab dann hier eine Phase des weißen Terrors, wo also hier Meinungsfreiheit etc.
Arg bekämpft wurde. Das kennt man ja dann schon, politische Gefangene,
Einschränkungen der Presse etc.
Und die taiwanesische Bevölkerung hat es dann aber eben geschafft,
über die Jahrzehnte durch permanenten Widerstand und dann auch nach dem Tod
von Chiang Kai-shek das Restregime so weit in die Knie zu zwingen,
dass ungefähr als es in Deutschland dann halt auch mit der Wiedervereinigung sich alles abspielte.
91 ist dann glaube ich so das letzte Gesetz, was Meinungsfreiheit unterbunden
hat, der berühmte Artikel 100 hier abgeschafft worden.
Und seitdem ist Taiwan eine recht lebendige,
offene, demokratische Gesellschaft geworden und man merkt richtig hier,
wie sehr Freiheit eine große Rolle spielt.
Wir sind übrigens auch gerade kurz vor einem wichtigen Jahrestag am 28.
Februar 1947 gab es hier irgendwie so ein ganz bedeutendes Massaker,
das war, wie ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Eigentlich aus einem Missverständnis heraus, wo dann Soldaten auf Leute geschossen
haben und das Ganze dann als Aufstand gewertet wurde.
Das war dann auch ein bisschen eingeleitet, diese ganze diktatorische Zeit und
das wird halt hier immer wieder so ein bisschen wie in Deutschland vielleicht so 17.
Juni Niederschlagung eines Widerstands immer wieder gefeiert und das wird dann
hier wahrscheinlich am Freitag auch in diversen Veranstaltungen münden,
die wir natürlich jetzt hier noch nicht gesehen haben.
Aber man merkt, dass den Taiwanesen das sehr wichtig ist und dass das hier wirklich
eine demokratische Kultur ist und man sich natürlich...
Nicht nur als Feind, aber zumindest Mainland China als Feind empfindet,
weil natürlich China gerne mit diesen ganzen demokratischen,
freiheitlichen Attitüden hier dem gerne ein Ende setzen möchte.
Ja, das von dir angesprochene 228, also der 28.
Februar, das war wirklich so der Infliction Point. Aber die Geschichte von Taiwan
ist halt auch eine, die sehr stark von Unterdrückung und Kolonialismus geprägt ist.
Also die indigene Bevölkerung hier wurde schon mal irgendwie von chinesischen
Immigranten unterdrückt über Jahrhunderte.
Dann kamen die Niederländer irgendwann einmal hierher, haben ihre Handelskolonien aufgebaut.
Die Japaner hatten ja auch eine starke Präsenz und hatten das teilweise als Kolonie geführt.
Der japanische kulturelle Einfluss wird heute aber auch eher positiv gesehen.
Man findet auch relativ viel japanische Architektur, Küche, vieles von der Technik
hier, von High-Speed-Trains bis Toiletten ist sehr japanisch angehaucht.
Cutification nicht zu vergessen.
Ob so überall Comicfiguren.
Ja, ja, Pärchen überall.
Cuteness-Faktor ist sehr hoch. Und gleichzeitig ist es natürlich aber auch so
wirklich der Infliction-Point. Also das von dir angesprochene Massaker am 28.
Februar, das war ja wirklich so eine Grunde, was die...
Die Zollbeamten oder Polizei, die eine Zigarettenverkäuferin,
die hat geschmuggelt, die Zigaretten verkauft hat, irgendwie kontrolliert haben
und da kam es zu einem Gerangel und dann auch zu einer Schießerei,
wo die Polizei beistehende Leute erschossen hat.
Eigentlich wollten die Protestierenden damals von den Behörden einfach nur Gerechtigkeit
für dieses Massaker haben, aber anstatt dem nachzukommen, ist man mit voller
militärischer Härte gegen die Protestierenden vorgegangen.
Und das hat halt auch zu der Einsetzung von Marshall Law, von Kriegsrecht geführt,
das ein Vierteljahrhundert hier auf dieser Insel gegolten hat bis 1985.
Und jetzt so in den letzten Jahrzehnten ist hier halt der große Turn gekommen.
Und inzwischen ist man sich sehr bewusst dieser Werte einer liberalen Demokratie
und hält das auch hoch im Angesicht eines viel größeren Landes,
das ja nur 180 Kilometer entfernt ist.
Also die taiwanesische Meerstraße trennt mainland China von Taiwan und 180 Kilometer
ist jetzt echt nicht lang, nicht breit.
Aber gleichzeitig sind diese zwei Länder kulturell, sprachlich,
historisch so eng miteinander verbunden.
Und nach dem Fall von Hongkong glaube ich, dass das hier das beste Beispiel ist,
wie eine Mandarin chinesisch sprechende Kultur eben doch mit liberalen Werten
und Demokratie vereinbar ist.
Nicht unähnlich, wie auch die Ukraine vielleicht für Russland so der Gegenpol
war. ah gut, das kann auch alles mit Demokratie und vielleicht auch mit Rechtsstaatlichkeit
gut funktionieren, was jedem Diktator natürlich ein Dorn im Auge ist.
Ja, der Bezug zur Ukraine ist dann auch auf der Konferenz zum Beispiel deutlich geworden.
Da gab es dann auch Panels dazu, wobei da auch schnell klargestellt wurde,
dass bei allen Parallelen man natürlich klar sehen muss, während es eben hier
wirklich dasselbe Volk ist, was letzten Endes sich aufgespalten hat in zwei
Systeme, ist das ja in der Ukraine nun mitnichten der Fall.
Also Ukrainer sind definitiv keine Russen und das ist ja auch sehr wichtig immer
wieder zu betonen in dieser ganzen Debatte.
Aber wollen wir nicht zu sehr abschweifen. Ja, also man spürt es hier,
es wird hier irgendwie zelebriert und vor allem, was ich bemerkenswert finde, ist,
was das hier für eine geordnete Kultur ist.
Also es ist schon streckenweise schon fast deutsch irgendwie in seiner Sauberkeit
und seiner Ordnungsliebe und wie hier die Leute an roten Ampeln stehen bleiben,
da steht in Deutschland nichts nach.
Ich würde sogar fast sagen, das ist noch ein bisschen schlimmer hier.
Ja und insofern alles ganz beeindruckend und wie das fast überall in Asien,
zumindest jetzt auf meiner Reise war,
sehr nette Leute, die einfach, also man wird hier sehr freundlich,
es wird einem hier sehr freundlich und sehr hilfsbereit begegnet auf allen Ebenen.
Und das ist auch keine übertriebene Höflichkeit, keine gespielte Höflichkeit,
sondern es ist einfach so.
Man merkt auch, wie das Land nach internationaler Anerkennung sich sehnt.
Also jegliche Erwähnung nur von Taiwan irgendwo auf der Welt ist hier gleich eine Nachricht.
Sondern auch, dass alle Länder, die Taiwan anerkennen, in irgendeiner Form von
China bestraft werden durch Handel, Liebesentzug, Geldentzug, was auch immer.
China ist mächtig genug, um da Druck auszuüben. Und wir sehen ja,
wie viele Länder da sich immer wieder zurücknehmen und darauf hoffend,
dass sie von China irgendwelche Investitionen für irgendwas erhalten.
Dafür dann eben sagen, okay, dann brechen wir unsere diplomatischen Beziehungen
zu Taiwan ab und sagen nicht, dass Taiwan einen Anspruch hat, zu existieren etc.
Pp. Das ist natürlich dann auch so ein wichtiger Punkt, wo man sich mal wieder
klar machen muss, wie wichtig auch so eine Anerkennung ist.
Und Taiwan ist insofern, wenn man was von Demokratie hält, mehr als nur yet
another country, sondern es ist fast schon eine Bastion,
die meiner Auffassung nach auf Biegen und Brechen gehalten werden muss und die
sozusagen die Unterstützung der Welt verdient.
Und wir sollen mal schauen, bisher war natürlich Taiwan immer ein Protektorat
der USA, das merkt man hier auch.
Also neben dem japanischen Einfluss gibt es hier auch einen starken US-amerikanischen
Einfluss und wenn es nur die 110 Volt Steckdosen sind.
Sie spielen Baseball, das ist auch so ein starkes Zeichen.
Also man merkt es hier und da, ich würde nicht sagen, dass die Gesellschaft
einem sehr amerikanisch rüberkommt, aber so das Straßendesign und das Stromdesign,
das ist so ein bisschen sehr amerikanisch geworden.
Das Stromdesign stört dich, okay.
Ich meine 120 Volt ist einfach nicht genug, sorry.
Du hast auf jeden Fall eine gewisse Nähe, aber ich meine, das ist auch verständlich,
wenn man in einer polaren Welt sich orientiert, das kleines Land,
dann hat man die Wahl zwischen zwei Polen.
Bisher haben die Amerikaner Taiwan auch nicht so draußen stehen lassen,
wie sie das bei der Ukraine gerade tun.
Also jetzt die neue Trump-Administration hat so leichte positive Zeichen gesetzt.
Einerseits gibt es ein Gemunkel über einen relativ großen Einkauf von Militärequipment
der USA hier nach Taiwan, so in der Größenordnung von sieben bis zehn Milliarden
Dollar werden da gemunkelt.
Es ist auf einer offiziellen Regierungswebseite der USA der Satz verschwunden,
dass man sich nicht für die Unabhängigkeit von Taiwan einsetzt,
was sofort zu starken Gegenreaktionen aus China geführt hat, wie es zu erwarten war.
Und es dürfte diese starke Anti-China-Haltung in der Trump-Administration vielleicht
auch zu einer gewissen Nähe zu Taiwan führen.
Es könnte aber auch sein, dass es rein pragmatische Gründe sind,
einfach dadurch, dass die Chip-Fertigung, die hier in dieser Insel passiert,
einfach ihresgleichen sucht und die Welt definitiv nicht ohne weiteres auf die
Chips von TSMC verzichten könnte.
Und da wird auch viel investiert, um das zu ändern.
In den USA und Europa werden ja Fabriken aufgebaut, die auch dieselbe Größenordnung
an Nanometer-Chips entwickeln können sollten. Aber ich glaube,
bisher sind wir noch nicht dort.
Und das ist sicherlich auch noch ein Silicon Shield, wie es hier in Taiwan heißt.
Am Ende des Tages muss man aber auch sehen, dass in Taiwan, wenn man ein bisschen
länger mit den Leuten redet, natürlich da auch Szenarien diskutiert werden.
Es gibt auch in der freien Demokratie, die es hier gibt, auch Parteien,
die sehr stark für eine Annäherung oder sogar eine Eingliederung unter China argumentieren.
Die haben nicht die Mehrheit, aber diese Stimmen gibt es. und zwischen einer
direkten militärischen Konfrontation und einer kompletten Unterwerfung gibt
es natürlich auch einen Mittelweg, der auch diskutiert wird,
ob es nicht eine Form von Verhandlungslösung geben könnte.
Ich weiß nicht, wie Sicherheitsgarantien aussehen, die da wirklich ein modellähnlich
Hongkong garantieren würden, dass man sagt,
okay gut, das hier wird zwar irgendwie Teil von China, aber die Freiheiten,
die Demokratie, die darf man behalten.
Dieses Versprechen wurde auch Hongkong gegeben und China hat sich nicht daran gehalten.
Aber solche Wege, solche Mittelwege werden zumindest hier auf der Insel auch diskutiert.
Ja, das kann ich auch nicht einschätzen, welche Bedeutung die haben.
Bei Wahlen war es schon auch ab und zu mal ein bisschen knapp,
wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man da China groß vertrauen kann.
Das hat Hongkong eigentlich wunderbar gezeigt.
Am Ende nehmen sie dann doch lieber die ganze Hand.
Und von daher kann ich das gut verstehen.
Ich denke, also wenn man hier mit Leuten darüber redet, kriegt man die unterschiedlichsten
Einschätzungen, kann man sich gut vorstellen, was sicherlich auf jeden Fall
auch verbreitet ist, ist generell diese,
Sichtweise, dass man hier insofern safe ist, weil man einerseits militärisch vorbereitet ist,
also Taiwan ist gut gerüstet, ob sie ausreichend gerüstet sind,
Und das weiß man nie.
Am Ende ist es eine Insel, da ist viel Wasser dazwischen, also ein Überfall
müsste also hier wirklich eine Anlandung nach sich ziehen.
Das ist militärisch natürlich sehr heikel, egal wie viel Luftüberlegenheit man
hat und man setzt hier glaube ich auch darauf,
dass China damit einfach sein ganzes Handelsreich mit dem Rest der Welt aufs
Spiel setzen würde und da ist sicherlich was dran.
Ob sie sich dann am Ende davon abhalten lassen oder denken, wir sind jetzt schon
stark genug und wir sind jetzt auch über den Punkt hinaus, wo alle anderen nicht
mehr ohne uns können und nicht umgekehrt, schwer zu sagen.
Naja, also das sind so unsere Eindrücke hier von Taiwan, das sind gute Eindrücke
und es ist angenehm hier.
Kann man also sehr empfehlen als Reiseland, als Besuchsland.
Du hast es schon gesagt, die Leute sind unheimlich freundlich,
es funktioniert alles und es ist auch ein relativ billiges Land, das muss man auch sagen.
Also vor allem, wenn man von Taipeh wegkommt, dann ist das Preisniveau wirklich
näher bei China als bei Europa.
Und es ist auch unheimlich viel Natur auf der Insel, die wirklich schön zu beobachten ist.
Es gab ein paar Erdbeben, dadurch sind manche der Parks aktuell geschlossen,
aber ansonsten gibt es hier genügend zu sehen.
Ein letzter Satz, der noch einfach, ein letzter Punkt, den ich erwähnen will,
wir waren ja auch relativ viel im Süden und da waren dann schon so zuerst tägliche
und dann wirklich so stündliche Military Flybys von Kampfjets und Helikoptern.
Also du merkst schon in gewissen Regionen und das war genau rund um dieses Statement
von den USA, was da entfernt wurde und einem kanadischen Schiff,
das halt hier durch die Meerstraße durchgefahren ist mit der erwartbaren Gegenreaktion von China.
Und das merkt man dann schon auch auf der Insel, dass hier Muskeln gefletscht werden.
Und das ist natürlich schon auch so etwas, das glaube ich die Stimmung beeinflusst.
Und wie du sagst, dieses gesehen werden vom Rest der Welt, das ist den Leuten
hier sehr wichtig und deswegen ist auch enorm viel Kommunikation da,
also wenn Leute irgendwie eng sprechen oder wenn man sich irgendwie verständigen kann,
dann sind es wirklich viele ehrliche und lange Gespräche.
Gut. So, aber jetzt mal zu dem Event, wo wir hier sind, die Ridescon.
Du warst schon mal auf einer, nehme ich an.
Ja, ich war, ich weiß gar nicht, auf wie vielen ich war.
Ich glaube in San Francisco, in Brüssel, Costa Rica, mehrere.
Es gibt so eine Liste. Ich glaube, dieses Event gibt es jetzt schon seit 15 Jahren ungefähr.
Oder das 15. Mal, natürlich ist es in der Pandemie ausgefallen.
Worum handelt es sich? Es ist eine globale Netzpolitik-Konferenz,
so in Größenordnung von einigen tausend Leuten.
Ich glaube aktuell sind es 3000 Participants und die findet immer irgendwo anders
auf der Welt statt. Früher war es immer so ein Ort irgendwo in der Welt und
dann einmal in den USA sozusagen.
Es ist immer gependelt zwischen San Francisco und irgendeinem anderen, in einer anderen Stadt.
Das hat man dann unter Trump aufgehört. Jetzt tut sie eigentlich nur so mehr durch die Welt.
Und was diese Konferenz auszeichnet, ist ihre Buntheit.
Es ist wirklich, es ist aus allen Ecken der Welt, so gut wie jedes Land, findet man Leute hier.
Es ist sehr aktivistisch, nicht nur netzpolitisch, aber alles hat einen gewissen Digitalbezug.
Heutzutage ist das aber auch etwas, wo natürlich auch jeder Demokratie-NGO,
Frauenrechts-NGO und so weiter haben heute netzpolitische Aspekte.
Also deswegen ist es hier auch sicherlich weitaus mehr als die klassischen Datenschutz-NGOs,
sondern wirklich ein breiteres Spektrum.
Und es ist auch von der Gender Balance her auf jeden Fall sehr angenehm und,
nicht nur eine Breitseite in eine Richtung.
Ich würde sogar fast sagen, ich sehe mehr Frauen als Männer.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen.
Also deutlich.
Es ist halt wirklich bunter und diverser, was auf jeden Fall auch dem Diskurs gut tut.
Ja, das Ganze wird organisiert von Access Now.
Die haben wir, glaube ich, in der Vergangenheit auch immer schon mal erwähnt.
Eine auch globale Netzpolitik-NGO, die mit relativ vielen MitarbeiterInnen in,
verschiedensten Regionen aktiv ist.
Die aus USA kommt.
Genau, also es ist auch eine starke amerikanische kulturelle Prägung,
aber natürlich, das tarierte sich dann über die Jahre immer so ein bisschen aus.
Ursprünglich kam die Kohle für Access Now, glaube ich, auch mal so aus der Zeit
des arabischen Frühlings und der Reaktion auf die Internet-Shutdowns gewisser
autokratischer Regime.
Da hat man so, glaube ich, das war noch Clinton Administration,
als Hillary Clinton Außenministerin war, einfach erkannt, gut,
wir müssen jetzt was tun, um sozusagen das Internet, das demokratieförderndes
Tool auch zu verteidigen in diesen Regionen.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen der Urschleim, aus dem Access Now hervorgegangen
ist und in der Folge natürlich macht so eine Konferenz besonders viel Sinn.
Thematisch ist es sehr breit also man findet von.
Internetzensur Staatstrojaner Content Governance Digital Identity eigentlich
wirklich quer durch alle möglichen Themen, die hier vertreten sind,
was den Diskurs betrifft es sind leider hauptsächlich Panels,
das halte ich für eine schlechte Entscheidung, ich glaube es wäre besser wenn
man hier mehr Vorträge hat Einfach nur damit dann gerne vielleicht auch kürzere
Slots, aber Leute wirklich gebündelt, das sagen können, was sie zu sagen haben,
anstatt einfach die ganze Zeit auf ein diskussives Format zu setzen,
wo man einfach nicht so in die Tiefe gehen kann.
Aber der Großteil der Vorträge hier sind in dem Format Panel.
Ja, du hast dir auch das Opening angeschaut.
Ja, das war relativ pompös.
Zehn Mal.
Na ja, also wie du zu erwarten, waren dann tatsächlich zwei sehr hochrangige
Vertreterinnen der Regierung, also Vizepremier und Vizepräsidentin.
Vizepremier, also auch eine Frau, beides Frauen.
Insbesondere die Vizepräsidentin hat wohl auch sehr viel Verdienste so im Bereich
Human Rights vorher schon eingesammelt ich kannte sie natürlich nicht,
aber hat auf jeden Fall eine gute Rede gehalten also haben sich halt alle präsentiert
natürlich Access Now auch und dann gab es ja viel Tamtam und immer so mit,
Wummer Musik zwischendurch bei jedem Auftritt ist ein bisschen so,
naja okay gut, kann man machen.
Und am Ende gab es dann sogar noch so eine Musik-Performance auf der Bühne von
so einem lokalen Chor- Rapper-Gespann irgendwie. Strange.
Ja, kann man machen. Das war irgendwie ganz okay. Ich bin allerdings ein bisschen
so vom ich habe ja immer so ein bisschen Veranstalter-Brille auf,
wenn ich auf so eine Veranstaltung gehe und bei Panels,
lege ich mich auch immer schon so ein bisschen mental zur Seite,
weil das einfach, Leute, wenn ihr eine Konferenz macht.
Und drüber nachdenkt, ein Panel zu machen, macht keins.
Panels sind ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz selten gut.
Aus einer ganzen Reihe von Gründen. Du hast es schon angesprochen.
Man kommt eigentlich nicht so in die Tiefe.
Wenn mal jemand seine Punkte wirklich klar bringen kann, dann ist es eher Zufall.
Hängt dann wiederum sehr von so einer Moderation ab.
Die Moderation hat aber andere Ziele. In der Moderation versucht dann immer
ein Gespräch, ein Fluss, eine Gleichberechtigung,
eine Verteilung, jetzt du, jetzt du herzustellen, nur irgendwie um die Zeit
gerecht zu verteilen und dann bleibt halt von so einer dreiviertel Stunde Session,
wo drei Personen sind, halt maximal zehn Minuten übrig und was soll das?
Also das halte ich einfach für Quatsch, das mag.
Also eine Diskussionsrunde finde ich wichtig, wenn… Konfrontativ.
Ja, es muss nicht unbedingt konfrontativ sein, aber wenn es sich um eine aktuelle Debatte handelt,
wo wirklich die Positionen unklar sind und wo man einfach mal ein paar Denker
zusammenbringen möchte,
die einfach da sich ein bisschen reingedacht haben, Aspekte machen,
um überhaupt erstmal so ein bisschen zu ergründen,
wie stehen wir dazu, wie sollte man damit umgehen.
Also etwas, wo klar ist, wo es ohnehin einen Streit gibt, sowas kann man dann
in so einer Diskussion gut auflösen.
Aber um klare Botschaften rüberzubringen, halte ich das für Quatsch.
Ich glaube, das wird immer alles so ein bisschen mehr unter diesem Aspekt gemacht, so ja,
wir wollen ja, dass viele wichtige Leute da sind und dann laden wir die halt
auf Panels ein und dann haben die irgendwie damit vielleicht auch schon ihr
Ticket und dann kommen die auch auf jeden Fall und das können wir dann in unser Programm schreiben,
gucken wir, wer alles da ist und am Ende geht es ja sowieso nur um die Gespräche im Flur.
Okay, kann man machen, finde ich aber dann trotzdem ein bisschen dünner für
die Beteiligten, weil wenn man da jetzt so hinkommt und man ist also wirklich
so auf Informationssuche, naja, so weiß ich nicht.
Also das könnte man dann halt auch effizienter haben.
Es gibt dann nebenbei auch noch so ein paar, ich würde es mal eher in so Workshops
machen, es startete am Anfang auch noch mit so selbstorganisierten Sachen,
die dann komischerweise nicht im Programm standen, das habe ich durch Zufall eher entdeckt.
Es sind auch so ein paar Technikaktivisten, hier Roger Dingeldein vom Tor-Projekt,
den habe ich getroffen, kurz gesprochen.
Und sicherlich auch noch ein paar andere vom Google Jigsaw Projekt und so.
Also verschiedene Leute, die halt
auch technisch für Freiheitstechnologie arbeiten, sind hier vertreten.
Aber man muss schon sagen, das ist hier zu 99 Prozent eine Policy-Veranstaltung.
Das heißt, die Leute, die hier sind, sind eigentlich gar nicht so sehr die Techniker,
sondern Leute, die einfach die politischen Diskussionen führen.
Und die ticken dann vielleicht auch nochmal ein bisschen anders und da habe
ich dann eine andere Perspektive.
Aber man merkt dann wiederum auch, wie stark Themen,
also das VPN-Thema, das hat mich völlig umgehauen, wie viele Sessions es irgendwie
gibt, die sich in irgendeiner Form mit VPNs beschäftigen, aus unterschiedlichen Perspektiven.
Halt dann auch alles irgendwie Panels.
Und bei einer Veranstaltung, wo ich war, wurden ein paar interessante Zahlen
genannt. Ich hoffe, ich kriege die jetzt korrekt wiedergegeben.
Ich befürchte nicht, es ging um den Iran. Und da wurden offizielle Zahlen des
Staates tatsächlich zitiert, die besagen,
dass 80 Prozent der Bevölkerung im Iran VPNs benutzen.
80 Prozent.
80, okay.
Es wurde dann aber auch, und deswegen wackele ich jetzt gerade,
dann gab es noch eine zweite Zahl mit 50%, da weiß ich nicht ganz genau, worauf sich das bezog.
Ich eiere es leider ein bisschen rum, ich mach's mal so.
Eine unglaublich große Zahl von Leuten benutzt VPNs,
und natürlich geht dann auch viel um die Frage, okay, was bringen diese VPNs,
werden die VPNs dann nicht mittlerweile genauso überwacht, wenn es so viele
sind und der Staat sich dessen bewusst ist, etc.
Welchem VPN kann man vertrauen?
Und da habe ich auch ein paar Gespräche geführt und es gibt ja auch diverse
VPN-Sponsoren auf dieser Veranstaltung, die dann auch in den Fluren sind und
ihre Produkte feil bieten.
Ja, also da habe ich noch keine richtige abschließende Meinung.
Mir ist nur aufgefallen, dass eben auch in so einer Policy-Szene,
die sich ja eigentlich um Politik und Einflussnahme und so weiter und Digital
Rights primär kümmert, der Technikaspekt sehr stark ist. Und da fand ich dann,
Da dachte ich mir dann so, okay, alles klar, da gibt es also schon eigentlich
eine Brücke zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt sagt Chaos Communication Kongress,
wo es ja vor allem viel um Technik geht, aber eben auch um diese ganzen Rechtsaspekte selbstverständlich.
Aber es gab hier glaube ich sogar so einen Service-Stand, wo man sein Telefon
auf Spyware untersuchen lassen konnte.
Das ist von Citizen Lab, die haben wir auch schon öfter erwähnt,
das Institut an der Universität in Toronto von Ron Dibert,
die genialste Arbeit machen im Bereich der Erkennung und Bekämpfung von Staatstrojanern,
Bundestrojanern und die haben hier einen Stand eigentlich schon seit einigen
Rights Cons und auch auf anderen Veranstaltungen, wo man einfach hingehen kann.
Und unter Anleitung einen System Diagnosis Report von seinem Telefon erstellt
und den schickt man dann über AirDrop, das Ganze ist glaube ich nur für Apple angeboten bisher.
An den Laptop von Citizen Lab und die lassen das dann einfach mal schnell durchlaufen
und überprüfen, ob bekannte Indikatoren, also Indicators of Compromise zu finden
sind in diesem Diagnosereport,
was ein Hinweis darauf sein kann, ob hier eine Stadtstrainer-Software installiert ist auf dem Gerät.
Das Ganze kostet natürlich nichts, ist damit verbunden, dass natürlich gewisse
Metadaten finden sich in diesem Diagnosereport,
aber es ist, finde ich, ein sehr nettes Service, was sie da anbieten,
sicherlich auch aus eigenem Interesse, dass sie das machen.
Und ja, ich war auch schon dabei, als da was gefunden wurde auf Telefonen.
Also von Leuten, die eine gewisse Regierungsnahe hatten und dann auf einmal
auch hier mit Pegasus, was in dem Fall,
sozusagen infiziert waren.
War aber nicht auf dieser Veranstaltung, sondern auf einer anderen.
Ah, okay. Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal nachfragen, wie die Findungsquote hier auf der RiceCon war.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie das veröffentlichen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall sicherlich
auch spannend. Und ich meine, es ist ja ein unheimlich hilfreiches Service.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass diese Indikatoren natürlich nicht vollständig sind.
Wenn hier nichts gefunden wird, heißt das nicht, dass keine Infektion vorhanden
ist. Das ist so wie ein Krebs-Screening.
Das sucht halt nach bekannten Markern, die vielleicht darauf schließen lassen,
dass hier etwas vorliegt, aber nur weil man da nichts findet,
heißt das nicht, dass nichts da ist.
Und Citizen Lab ist sowieso eine wunderbare Organisation. Wir hatten am...
Sonntag auch ein Treffen von allen Organisationen, die am Thema Spyware arbeiten
und da waren die auch ganz stark vertreten.
Ja und das ist vielleicht auch ein guter Segway, so ein Thema,
das ja natürlich auch in ganz vielen Gesprächen Widerhalt ist,
einfach der komplette Zusammenbruch der Funding-Landschaft.
In den USA wurde ja USAID, wie nennt man das so?
Abgewickelt.
Abgewickelt, ja. Ich hätte eher einen Begriff aus einer Fleischerei gewählt, also gegattet.
Das ist so richtig bei lebendigem Leib.
Culling, ja.
Und das betrifft natürlich ganz viele Organisationen, vor allem jene im globalen
Süden, die jetzt natürlich auch ganz viel von ihrem Funding umfallen,
das für sie essentiell war.
Teilweise betrifft es auch einige große Organisationen, die Access Now,
Article 19 zum Beispiel, denen auch sehr viel Funding wegfällt,
was sie eben auch aus den Entwicklungshilfetöpfen der Welt bekommen haben.
Und insgesamt gibt es dadurch diesen Effekt, dass auch der Wettbewerb zwischen
NGOs natürlich stärker wird und der Konkurrenzdruck, das verbleibende Funding.
Eines der interessantesten Side-Events, an dem ich teilnehmen durfte,
war das Executive Directors Meeting.
Das gibt es seit der RightsCon in Toronto und das ist ein Treffen von allen
Menschen, die eine netzpolitische Organisation leiten.
Ich bin ja selber ED von Epicenter Works und da kommen dann eben so ganz am
Anfang in Toronto, glaube ich,
20, inzwischen sind wir 90 Leute aus wirklich allen Weltregionen und auch allen Arten von NGOs.
Teilweise sind das zum Beispiel vietnamesische Demokratieorganisationen oder
philippinische Frauenrechtsorganisationen.
Es ist wirklich sehr, sehr breit und das hat natürlich ein bisschen den Charakter
in der Selbsthilfegruppe.
Gleichzeitig ist es unheimlich spannend zu schauen, wie viele Parallelen es
dann doch gibt in den Problemzugängen und was man tun muss, um so eine Organisation
stabil auf Kurs zu halten, zu finanzieren,
den Staff glücklich zu halten und da gibt es viel Austausch.
Also das ist wirklich so fast auch eines der Highlights dieses Events.
Und was kann man da mal noch irgendwie erwähnen?
Also von den Dingen, die hier anstande sichtbar waren,
fand ich irgendwie das hier am lustigsten, Flash Drives for Freedom,
ist eine Initiative von der Human Rights Foundation.
Und die schauen, dass sie USB-Sticks mit Medieninhalten,
mit Nachrichteninhalten, mit Filmen, mit all dem, was in Nordkorea verboten
und nicht verfügbar ist, zu den Menschen dort bringen.
Und das tun sie, indem sie so Plastikflaschen mit Reis auffüllen,
da Geld und einen USB-Stick reingeben und das Ganze dann mit Helion-Luftballons
über die Grenze schicken.
Damit wird versucht, so mehrere Probleme zu lösen. Einerseits mal irgendwie
prinzipiell Reis und Essen dahin zu
bringen, weil es gibt ja eine enorme Lebensmittelknappheit in Nordkorea.
Da verhungern die Menschen ja am laufenden Meter, auch irgendwie ausländisches
Geld dahin zu schaffen, harte Currency, aber eben auch diese USB-Sticks.
Und ich fand das sehr spannend und habe mich relativ lange mit denen unterhalten.
Es war mir auch nicht bewusst so, ja, gibt es da dann überhaupt Geräte,
um diese USB-Sticks auszulesen?
Ja, gibt es, weil die haben zwar kein Internet, aber die haben alle DVD-Abspielegeräte.
Und die haben USB-Port. Das heißt, über die kann man dann den UN-Menschenrechtsreport
über die Vorgänger in Nordkorea halt lesen.
Über die kann man sich die Bücher von Dissidentinnen aus Nordkorea zuführen
und damit halt mitbekommen, wie es jemandem geht, der es aus diesem Regime rausgeschafft hat.
Und unheimlich wichtige Arbeit, durchaus nicht unkritisch. Ich habe auch so
gefragt, wie sie das reflektieren, dass natürlich jetzt jemand,
der diese Wasserflasche mit diesem USB-Stick auffängt,
natürlich auch einer Gefahr ausgesetzt ist.
Also mit derartigem Material gefunden zu werden, kann natürlich dazu führen,
dass man sehr starke Konsequenzen von dem dortigen Regime ausgesetzt ist.
Und nicht nur die Person, sondern auch die komplette Familie.
Ja, aber das haben sie halt auch so argumentiert. Ja, die Hoffnung ist aber,
dass über diese Information die Leute...
Näher dem Ziel kommen, dieses Regime zu stürzen und dass man ihnen so auf lange
Sicht was Gutes tut, indem man sie nicht alleine lässt und dieser absoluten
Echo-Kammer Nordkorea ausgesetzt lässt.
Und hat natürlich auch so gewisse Parallelen zu der deutsch-österreichischen
Geschichte mit so den Flugblättern in der Nazizeit.
Natürlich ist das gefährlich für jene, die diese Informationen auch nur aufsammeln.
Lustig ist auch irgendwie die Reaktion von Nordkorea natürlich,
so sehr Trumpisch sie schicken jetzt auch Heliumluftballons nach Südkorea runter
aber halt mit Scheiße drauf also mit so vollgeschissenen Windeln es ist glaube
ich so sehr Diktator Trump like.
Ihr solltet euch die Webseite auf jeden Fall anschauen nur um des Logos willen
wo ein Kim Jong-Un abgebildet ist Also anstatt seines Mundes sieht man so eine
USB-A-Buchse und das sieht irgendwie doch sehr lustig aus,
wenn man ihm dann irgendwie so einen Flash Drive ins Maul packt.
Ja, interessantes Projekt. Ja, Nordkorea, das größte Open-Air-Gefängnis der
Welt, definitiv. Das kann man nicht anders sagen.
Also da werden die Leute im Prinzip alle in Freilufthaft gehalten.
Und ja, Nahrungsmittelkrise, Informationskrise. Da ist also jede nur irgendwie
erdenkliche Krise am Start und in Nordkorea zu leben, heißt einfach jeden Tag
ums Überleben zu kämpfen auf jeder Ebene.
Naja, also das tummelt sich hier alles auf dieser Ridescon.
Insofern ein interessanter Einblick für mich ohnehin, weil ich das erste Mal
auf dieser Ridescon bin.
Ja und dazu noch das erste Mal in Taiwan, da kommt einiges zusammen.
Vielleicht ein letzter Punkt noch, den man erwähnen sollte, ist,
diese Konferenz hier hat Sponsoren, was ja auch ein großer Unterschied ist zum
Kongress, zu CCC-Events.
Wenn man sich mal so die Liste anschaut, sind da irgendwie so einige Stiftungen,
vor allem eben aus dem Entwicklungshilfe-Bereich wie SIDA, das sind glaube ich
die Schweden, Luminate, die niederländische Regierung, Kanada,
aber eben auch Google, Microsoft, Meta, Netflix, Cloudflare.
Und es ist auch so die Frage, wer von denen nächstes Jahr hier noch vertreten
sein wird, weil bisher war es für viele Big-Tech-Konzerne,
Schon so eine Frage des Value-Signalings, wir nehmen Menschenrechte wichtig,
wir wollen zeigen, dass wir der Verantwortung unserer Plattformen gerecht werden
und nach der Trump-Inauguration mit den Big Tech-CEOs in der Galerie,
erste Reihe fußfrei auf den teuersten Plätzen,
glaube ich, dass man sich da auch fragen sollte, ob eine solche Unterstützung
in Zukunft überhaupt noch passieren wird.
Vielleicht ist das auch eine Chance. Ich bin der Meinung, dass man eher eine
gesunde Distanz zu diesen Unternehmen wahren sollte.
Aber de facto gibt es halt auch sehr viel von dieser Arbeit,
vor allem in anderen Weltregionen, die durchaus finanziert wird.
Und das ist so ein bisschen auch ein interessantes Timing.
Wir sind jetzt ja Ende Februar hier.
Die Trump-Administration ist noch relativ kurz in Amt und Würden.
Und alles wurde hier ja schon im Vorfeld finanziert und ausgemacht und gedealt.
Also ich glaube, dass dieses Event sich nächstes Jahr sehr stark verändern wird
und dieser neuen Realität auch mehr gerecht wird.
Im Moment ist es alles so eher, es passiert, während wir hier sind,
aber es hat sich noch nicht so ganz entfaltet.
Das einzige Gesprächsthema, was relativ stark ist, ist, dass sehr viele Leute
sich schon nach einem neuen Job umschauen.
Also es wird schon relativ viel neu gemischt.
Und in einem Jahr wird es sicherlich sehr spannend, ob es diese Konferenz noch
gibt und in welcher Form und wo sie auftreten wird.
Oder ob es neue Sponsoren gibt, die mal aus anderen Ländern kommen können.
Mehr VPN-Anbieter.
Gut, ja, ich habe noch eine Netzentralität-Session, die ist aber erst morgen,
darüber kann man jetzt noch nicht reden.
Und es gibt diese Human Rights for ID Coalition, die ich nur kurz erwähnen wollte.
Leider haben die noch keine Webseite, aber das ist ein super tolles Netzwerk
von NGOs aus der ganzen Welt, die sich mit digitaler Identität beschäftigen,
auch hauptsächlich aus dem Global South und da glaube ich auch,
dass sehr viel tolle Arbeit gerade passiert.
Da gab es auch nochmal dann am Morgen ein Treffen dazu.
Gut, dann lass uns einen großen Sprung machen und nach Deutschland schauen, oder?
Ja, da war ja was. Wir haben das natürlich hier alles nur aus der Ferne mit
einer im höchsten Maße inkompatiblen Zeitzone verfolgen können,
aber es gab natürlich Bundestagswahl.
Und ja, ich habe das jetzt alles nicht so gefühlt, weil ich war jetzt auch den
ganzen Wahlkampf über eigentlich gar nicht vor Ort und muss auch sagen,
ich habe es nicht vermisst.
Ja wie ist es ausgegangen ihr wisst es eh alle schon wir werden also jetzt demnächst
wahrscheinlich mit einer CDU SPD der wie man früher sagte,
großen Koalition die so groß jetzt gar nicht mehr ist weil sie nicht aus zwei
40% besteht sondern einer Partei die es noch nicht mal auf 30% gebracht hat 28.
Was war das 28,5% für die CDU und der SPD, die auf 16,4 Prozent kam.
Dazwischen die AfD mit einer Verdopplung ihres letzten Ergebnisses auf 20,8
Prozent der Zweitstimmen.
Die Grünen bei 11,6, zwar mit 3,1 Prozent Verlust, aber trotzdem eigentlich
immer noch in ihrer Gesamtgeschichte mit einem relativ guten Ergebnis,
haben aber definitiv Federn lassen müssen, offensichtlich vor allem an die Linke.
Ich habe jetzt nicht auf Wählerwanderungsdiagramme gestarrt,
das ist jetzt nur so meine Interpretation, aber ich denke das ist relativ klar,
denn die Linke ist auch fast mit einer Verdopplung in den Bundestag wieder gewählt
worden, ist auf 8,8 Prozent gekommen und gerade so eben nicht geschafft hat.
Es das BSW und nicht geschafft hat.
Deutlich ja nicht geschafft, die FDP und alle sonstigen Parteien,
die noch so angetreten sind und manchen Leuten wichtig sind oder nicht wichtig sind.
Ja, womit wir eben die beunruhigende Situation haben,
dass die AfD sich noch mehr Mittel aus dem Bundestag einstreichen kann und noch
mehr Präsenz dort bekommt und noch mehr von ihren Rechtslastigen und Extremen
im Parlament sich ihr Gehalt abholen dürfen.
Und ja, man kann einfach nur weiterhin beobachten,
dass so die Mitte der Gesellschaft offensichtlich nicht daran interessiert ist,
in irgendeiner Form irgendwas voranzubringen und wir jetzt weitere vier Jahre
Stillstandsverwaltung betreiben werden und das ist alles sehr beunruhigend.
Ja, ich Ich mache das nicht gerne, aber es ist leider wirklich ein Déjà-vu aus
einer österreichischen Perspektive.
Weil das Grundproblem wird sein, dass wenn es eigentlich Reformen bräuchte,
aber keine gemeinsame Vision da ist,
auf einem sterbenden Planeten mit immer mehr globalen Krisen nichts tun,
heißt die Situation wird schlimmer.
Und je schlimmer sie wird, umso mehr profitieren jene davon,
die alles anzünden wollen und einen billigen Feind anzubieten haben.
Und ich finde das sehr löblich, dass die Brandmauer in Deutschland als Konstrukt
noch da ist und noch hoch gehalten wird.
In Österreich war die ja nie wirklich da.
Und ich würde mir wünschen für Deutschland, dass sie hält, aber das ist jetzt
sicherlich eine Belastungsprobe.
Definitiv und das wird natürlich jetzt so weiter gehen. Man sieht ja auch schon,
wie der Springer Verlag schon komplett umgesattelt hat und schon so mit Elon
Musk Methoden sozusagen auf die Gesellschaft einschlägt.
Schuld sind ja immer die Grünen und so.
Schuld sind in allem die Grünen, auch an den ganzen Gesetzen,
die schon die CDU beschlossen hat.
Das Spiel läuft halt weiterhin. Wir haben eine Erstarkung auch solcher neuer rechter Medien,
die aufpoppen und die Bild-Zeitung lässt sich ja sehr ungern die Butter vom
Brot nehmen und hat überhaupt gar keine Probleme damit, sich da weiter zu radikalisieren.
Ja, so läuft der Hase. Von Merz halte ich persönlich gar nichts.
Ich glaube, der Typ ist einfach nur inkompetent und Angela Merkel ist zwar jetzt
auch nicht gerade besonders hoch angesehen mit ihrem Wirken ihrer 16 Jahre.
Ich meine, es war ja im Prinzip auch nur so Stillstandsanrührung.
Aber nicht mal sie mag ihn. Und der Typ hatte halt keine politische Erfahrung.
Der war niemals Ministerpräsident, der hat irgendwie kein Amt irgendwie geleitet,
der war halt nur im Bundestag, bis Merkel ihn irgendwie klein gehalten hat,
dann ist er abgehauen, hat sich in der freien Wirtschaft rumgeschlagen bei BlackRock
und irgendwie anderen da in,
Vorstandsetagen reingesetzt und seine Kohle gemacht und mit seinem Privatjet
durch die Gegend geflogen.
Ja, und dann als irgendwie Merkel gesagt hat, ich mache jetzt nicht mehr,
dann ist er halt irgendwie wiedergekommen und jetzt hat er es halt irgendwie
geschafft, sich da an die Spitze zu setzen und natürlich tun jetzt wieder alle
so, als wäre er der große Visionäre Vorsitzende, aber ich glaube,
der Typ hat halt einfach keine Ahnung.
Und das haben wir ja auch schon gesehen, wie er sich dann eben bei dieser Abstimmung
da mit seinem blöden Zustrom Durchsetzungsgesetz.
Begrenzungsgesetz, Entschuldigung, Zustrom, Begrenzung, also dieses Wort,
ja, also voll so auf diesen Train gesetzt hat und gezeigt hat,
so, ich habe keine Haltung.
Das war ja im Prinzip die Botschaft. Und jetzt kann er sich natürlich dafür
feiern, dass er noch 8% mehr hatte als die Nazis,
aber da sage ich nur so, das ist einfach für die CDU schon ein absolutes Armutszeugnis
und nichts deutet darauf hin,
dass er sich halt auch weiterhin da absetzen wird.
Das behauptet er dann zwar, weil er jetzt irgendwie sich ausgerechnet hat,
dass es die AfD eben nicht braucht für eine Koalition, wie wir es ja in Österreich
haben, da reden wir auch gleich nochmal drüber.
Und fühlte sich dann da wohl sicher, da groß einen drauf zu hauen.
Aber letzten Endes hat er ja auch nur gezeigt, dass alle dann irgendwie nie
den Mut haben in der Wahl.
Kann das bei der Wahl ein bisschen...
Und nachvollziehen im Sinne von, ich kann es nachvollziehen,
wie der Apparat da arbeitet, nicht, dass ich es genauso machen würde oder möchte,
dass es genauso gemacht wird,
dass man sagt, okay, das sind die Themen, über die alle reden,
da müssen wir uns so positionieren und wenn wir da jetzt dagegen sind,
gegen den aktuellen Medienstrom, wenn wir gegen die Bild-Zeitung arbeiten,
dann können wir nur verlieren.
Das ist sowieso die normale politische Logik und man darf nie unterschätzen,
welche Präsenz diese Mediendebatten eben haben, die ja dann zunehmendem Maße
auf Social Media stattfinden und dort eben von den ganzen rechten Playern einfach
hochgejazzt werden, also TikTok und so weiter.
Ich meine, wenn du heute irgendwie TikTok öffnest und du hast keinen Account,
wie bei Twitter, das ist halt einfach alles nur noch Hetze und Beschwerde und
einfach sehr viel Negatives.
Und dieses Mantra der Rechten immer zu behaupten, es wäre ja alles ganz,
ganz, ganz furchtbar und alles ganz schlimm und die Welt wäre kurz vor dem Weltuntergang,
obwohl wir ja wissen, dass sie bei 0,00017% ist, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass...
Immer so ein Gefühl erzeugt wird von gleich ist alles vorbei und die Bedrohung
ist da und keiner hat einfach die Werbe mal zu sagen, Leute,
so schlimm ist jetzt auch nicht.
Andererseits muss man aber auch klar sagen, und da ist die CDU und natürlich
auch die SPD bei aller Liebe keine wirkliche Kraft.
Natürlich gibt es Leute, die sich abgehängt fühlen in der Gesellschaft,
weil wir natürlich ein Umverteilungsproblem haben, gar keine Frage.
Aber guck dir dann mal an, was die als Steuermaßnahmen alles so vorschlagen.
Daran ändert sich halt gar nichts für die Leute. Also dieser Trend,
dass Leute einfach immer gegen ihre eigenen Interessen stimmen,
weil sie sich eben von so kurzfristigen Meinungsbildern, die durch Medien,
egal ob sie nun sozial sind oder nicht.
Hervorgerufen werden, davon ablenken lassen und letzten Endes für etwas wählen,
was gegen ihre eigenen Interessen sind, weil sie diesen politischen Komplex nicht verstehen.
Das ist die Story, die gibt es schon immer und die wird es immer geben.
Damit muss man irgendwie arbeiten und man kann jetzt lange darüber diskutieren,
ob man da mit dem Strom mitschwimmen muss, um irgendwie nicht abgehängt zu werden
durch diese Debatte oder ob man sich halt den Rücken durchdrückt und sagt so, nö,
ich bleibe jetzt mal hier standhaft und stehe einfach mal für etwas ein,
von dem ich denke, dass es eben wirklich was bringt.
Aber ja, dann keine Ahnung, dann ziehen sich wahrscheinlich die großen Donors
aus dem Hintergrund wieder zurück, weil die wollen halt irgendwie Steuersenkungen
für das Big Business haben.
Und dann haben sie wieder Angst, dass sie ihren Parteitag nicht finanziert bekommen
und ihren Wahltag schon gar nicht im Wahlkampf.
Und so dreht sich halt eigentlich immer wieder alles im Kreis.
Und es bräuchte Reformen wahrscheinlich auf allen Ebenen, im Parteiengesetz,
in der Finanzierung und so weiter, aber da haben wir einfach den Willen nicht für.
Und vor allem auch in Deutschland, was ich ja immer beklage,
auch überhaupt gar kein kollektives Verständnis für den Zustand,
in dem sich dieses Land mittlerweile befindet, der einfach nicht gut ist und
der nicht zukunftsorientiert ist.
Und diese selbstgefühlte Vorreiterrolle, die Deutschland angeblich in irgendwelchen
Bereichen hat, wirtschaftlich, irgendwie energiepolitisch, was weiß ich,
das sind alles nur noch Illusionen und da ist man einfach weit hinterher.
Ja, ich meine, ich glaube schon, es wäre die Zeit, jetzt wirklich größere Reformprojekte
anzugehen. Und noch hätte man die Chance.
Klar wäre es die Zeit. Es war schon immer die Zeit. Vor zehn Jahren wäre die
Zeit auch schon gewesen.
Aber ich meine, hast du Hoffnung, dass diese Regierung, diese sogenannte Große
Koalition, wo sie denn zustande kommt, diese Zeichen der Zeit erkannt hat,
dass sie jetzt entweder etwas ändert oder sich selbst abschafft?
Und glaubst du, dass die diese vier Jahre Legislaturperiode auch durchstehen werden?
Durchstehen, ja klar, weil die
CDU lässt sich die Butter nicht vom Brot nehmen. Das schafft nur die SPD.
Die werden das durchziehen. Am Ende wird die SPD noch weniger Stimmen bekommen.
Das würde ich jetzt schon fast eine Wette drauf abschließen.
Das war bisher nach jeder großen Koalition so.
Und, wobei jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, vielleicht erzähle ich gerade Unsinn in
Bezug auf die letzte Wahl,
aber anyway, nein, wenn du mich fragst, ob ich eine Hoffnung habe, habe ich nicht.
Ich lasse mich gerne überraschen, gar kein Problem, aber wenn du mich nach Hoffnung
fragst, ich habe keine Hoffnung.
Und dann die andere Frage, wirklich ehrlich gefragt, also ich weiß,
das ist jetzt so irgendwie, man sich wahrscheinlich freut über die Parteien,
die es nicht reingeschafft haben,
aber jetzt rein nur mal vom Wahlsystem, das sind so grob 13 Prozent der Stimmen,
die nicht repräsentiert sind im Bundestag. Ist das nicht ein Problem?
Ja, kann man drüber diskutieren.
Also meine, persönlich muss ich sagen, bin ich jetzt nicht so traurig darüber,
dass es BSW und FDP nicht geschafft haben, wobei ich glaube, die FDP wäre auch,
sagen wir mal schon mit so einem niedrigen Stimmenanteil vielleicht auch schon
ausreichend bestraft gewesen.
Sodass es vielleicht nicht unbedingt jetzt, die Welt geht nicht unter,
weil die FDP dann auch noch mit ein paar Hanseln im Bundestag vertreten ist.
Und wenn man halt erstmal so ein bisschen kleingedrückt wird,
dann ist man ja auch schon bestraft
und dann ändert man vielleicht seine Perspektive. Das kann schon sein.
Im Falle vom BSW,
naja also da muss ich sagen, da habe ich natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen meine,
Ukraine geprägte Sicht gerade das ist für mich halt so Parteien.
Die nach Personen benannt sind haben.
Die Sozialversorgung das kommt noch dazu also Sarah Wagenknecht ist halt auch
eine Opportunistin vor dem Herrn, ich meine die kommt aus dem,
kommunistischen Block in der Linken repräsentiert.
Und ist jetzt irgendwie erste Stimme, wenn es darum geht, gegen,
Migranten zu hetzen. Und das ist halt sehr verstörend. Und du hast schon recht.
Also Parteien, die nach Personen genannt sind, also dieser Personenkult,
das ging die ganze Zeit schon gar nicht.
Dann hat sie dann halt so die Linke gespalten. Man muss sagen,
die Linke hat dabei jetzt wahrscheinlich gewonnen, weil...
Die Sarah Wagenknecht war, glaube ich, für viele auch ein Hauptgrund,
bei der Linken keinerlei Glück zu finden.
Und es hat sich halt jetzt schon, und es wird jetzt mal interessant sein zu
sehen, was sich da alles eigentlich jetzt wirklich rausgespalten hat.
Ich habe natürlich persönlich mit dieser russlandfreundlichen Haltung des BSW
von Sarah Wagenknecht speziell meine Probleme.
Also das ist irgendwie so Hufeisen Deluxe.
Inwiefern jetzt die von der Heidi Reichenig neu aufgestellte Linke dort eine
liberalere Position aufnehmen, muss man sehen.
Also es gibt sicherlich viele Abgeordnete bei den Linken, die sehr wohl pro-Ukraine
mäßig eingestellt sind und einfach Russland gerade als das sehen,
was es ist, nämlich eine Bedrohung.
Allerdings wird es knifflig bei der Haltung, und das ist ja auch immer das Problem
mit der Linken im Bundestag in Bezug auf potenzielle Koalitionen im Bund,
wie sie dann eben zu einer Aufrüstung stehen werden.
Weil ich glaube, da werden sich dann halt sehr schnell wieder die grundsätzlichen Stimmen melden,
die sagen, das geht ja gar nicht und jetzt sind wir hier auf dem Weg in einen
Militärstaat und deswegen dürfen wir unsere Rüstungsausgaben nicht erhöhen.
Und das Problem ist, dass die Linken halt in der Hinsicht zusammen mit der AfD
eine Sperrminorität irgendwie auch aufmachen können für größere Entscheidungen.
Und das muss man mal schauen, wohin die Reise da geht.
Die Sperrminorität würde es eine Verfassungsmehrheit brauchen, meinst du?
Ja, wenn man halt irgendwie Grundgesetz irgendwie was ändern wollen würde etc.
Schauen wir mal. Also ich bin erstmal im Großen und Ganzen muss sagen,
das hätte schlimmer kommen können.
Das mit der AfD ist schlimm, gar keine Frage.
20 Prozent, das geht einfach gar nicht. das schmerzt mich persönlich sehr,
dass es mehr Nazis gibt als Leute, die der Meinung sind, dass die Grünen irgendwie
eine produktive Kraft sind. Kann man zu den Grünen ja stehen, wie man will.
Die Linke muss sich beweisen, sie haben halt die jungen Leute aufgenommen, die halt sehr.
Belebt wurden durch das Auftreten dieser Heidi Reichenegg, die ja irgendwie
die sozialen Medien dominiert hat, mit einer klaren Haltung, muss man sagen.
Das war auch gut, dass sie das gemacht hat, dass sie eine klare Position eingenommen hat, dass sie,
da kein Blatt vor den Mund nimmt und das auch sehr elegant hingelegt hat. Ja, also,
Und es sind ja auch in dem Lager der Linken auch viele engagierte junge Bundestagsabgeordnete,
die halt mit kleinen Anfragen etc.
Mit konkreter politischer Arbeit was beitragen. die auch, sagen wir mal,
ein wichtiger Gateway sind, glaube ich, für viele NGOs auch in den Bundestag
rein, wie die Grünen ja auch.
Von daher hätte es schlimmer kommen können und ja, und vielleicht nochmal deine
Frage mit dieser 5% Stufe, wie ist denn das in Österreich geregelt?
4%.
Na ja gut, ich meine, da kann man jetzt drüber diskutieren, ob 4% irgendwie
besser, gerechter, richtiger ist als 5, das ist am Ende nur eine Zahl.
Man könnte auch sagen, ja, warum nicht 3% oder warum nicht 2% und am Ende wird
es immer so ein bisschen davon abhängen, ja, okay, wie viel willst du raushalten?
Oder was verhindert das eigentlich? Du bist ja ohnehin mit so einer niedrigen
Zahl eh schlechter aufgestellt, weil du dann unter Umständen gar nicht Fraktionsgröße hast.
Das ist ja dann immer bei solchen Aufspaltungen so gewesen, beziehungsweise
als die Linken noch in den Bundestag kamen, nicht weil sie 5% erreicht haben,
sondern es gab ja noch diese andere Klausel mit den drei gewonnenen Direktmandaten.
Das hat sich jetzt geändert durch das neue Wahlrecht, was ich ehrlich gesagt
selbst nicht hundertprozentig durch,
verstanden habe, was es ist, aber im Kern ist es so, gab es bei den Wahlen bisher
immer die Garantie, dass ein gewonnener Wahlkreis auch in ein Direktmandat mündet,
ist es jetzt eben Nicht so, sondern das neue Wahlrecht besagt,
wenn deine Zweitstimmen nicht ausreichen, dann werden nicht weitere Plätze geschaffen,
sodass noch mehr Leute von der Liste reinkommen,
sondern das geht jetzt bei den Direktmandaten.
Was ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig verstehe, weil gerechter wäre es gewesen,
zu sagen, na dann gehen halt einfach nicht so viele Listenplätze rein.
Dann geht es einfach von der Liste ab, von der bundesweiten Liste.
So nach dem Motto, Direktmandat gewonnen ist, Direktmandat ist gewonnen.
Du vertrittst halt deinen Wahlkreis.
Jetzt gibt es quasi Wahlkreise, die so nicht von ihrem Hauptgewinner vertreten werden.
Wie viel das ausmacht, weiß ich nicht, aber bedeutet im Prinzip eine Änderung
der politischen Kultur im Bundestag oder der Vertretungskultur zumindest.
Und natürlich haben sie das eben nicht so gemacht, dass es dann von der Liste
weg geht, weil da sitzen ja dann die Großkopfwarten, die sich halt irgendwie absichern wollen.
Und wenn es dann auf einmal Schwankungen gibt und die irgendwie reingenden Wahlkreise
nicht gewinnen, dann kriegt man dann die Leute darüber nicht rein.
Also das ist, weiß ich auch nicht.
Ob das jetzt der große Wurf war im Wahlgesetz, das musste ja geändert werden, weil das,
Verfassungsgericht halt gesagt hat, ihr müsst das ändern, weil sich durch diese
vielen Parteien und durch die Wahlergebnisse der Bundestag immer weiter aufgebläht
hat und immer mehr Sitze bereitgestellt werden mussten,
um sozusagen diese Zweitstimmenanteile auszugleichen und jetzt,
schlägt das Pendel ein bisschen anders aus, machen wir mal gucken,
welche Auswirkungen das am Ende.
Die Demokratie hat ein Platzproblem.
Ja, es ist definitiv nicht genug Platz in der Demokratie.
Ja, aber ihr habt ja auch, glaube ich, mehr Abgeordneten oder fast so viele
wie das Europaparlament, oder? Sind doch auch so.
Ja, jetzt sind es ja nicht mehr so viele. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht,
wie viele es sind. Ich muss nur noch nachschauen.
Deutsches Wahlrecht, ich kenne mich zwar wenig aus.
Das ist spannend. Also ich wünsche euch viel Glück.
Danke. Ich wünsche dir auch, dass wir viel Glück haben.
Ich meine, Deutschland ist ja jetzt nicht ganz unentscheidend in der Hinsicht.
Noch seid ihr nicht unregierbar. Aber das ist die gute Überleitung zu Österreich. Unregierbar.
Wir hatten auch Wahlen im September letzten Jahres. Regierung haben wir noch keine.
Also ihr habt schon noch eine Regierung, die alte. Die ist ja sozusagen noch in, tut die noch was?
Also ist die noch in der Lage, mit dem neuen Parlament irgendwas zu beschließen?
Die haben ja keine Mehrheit mehr. Also die ÖVP gemeinsam mit den Grünen hat
bei Weitem keine Mehrheit mehr im neu gewählten Nationalrat.
Aber natürlich sind die MinisterInnen noch im Amt.
Aber sie könnten doch theoretisch jetzt auch noch Gesetze einbringen und darüber
abstimmen lassen. Und dann würde es ja letzten Endes nur auf an den Neos hängen.
Das müsste man sich anschauen. Also es können natürlich jetzt,
und das passiert auch noch, dass Gesetze eingebracht werden,
wo aber natürlich im freien Spiel der Kräfte mal geschaut werden muss,
ob es dafür überhaupt eine Mehrheit gibt.
Das sind aber jetzt eher so Value Signaling Sachen, so hey, das wollten wir
doch gerne machen, schau, hier wäre unser Angebot, lasst uns das noch regeln.
Das ist jetzt nicht ausgedealt mit dem, komm, wir machen jetzt noch irgendwie hier Projekte,
hat in Österreich auch nicht so viel Kultur, außer halt in der Zeit vor der
Wahl im freien Spiel der Kräfte, um noch ordentlich viel Steuergeld auszugeben
und Wahlzucker zu verteilen.
Aber wir sind ja nach der Wahl, die Wahl, die ausging,
Ich will jetzt keinen Deutschlandvergleich machen, aber es ist halt doch,
Österreich ist schon länger auf diesem Pfad, leider.
Und bei uns hat die FPÖ, also die österreichische AfD, ja die Wahl gewonnen mit 28 Prozent.
Und zweiter Platz ging an die, lass mich jetzt nochmal nachschauen.
Die ÖVP, oder?
Die ÖVP, genau. Und dann war die SPÖ.
Ist die ÖVP dann auch bei 20 Prozent gelandet?
Nein, die ist bei 26 Prozent. Also FPÖ und ÖVP liegen zwei Prozent auseinander.
Und die SPÖ dann abgeschlagen mit 21, darunter auf Platz 3.
NEOS haben es ebenso reingeschafft auf Platz 4 mit 9 und Grüne mit 8.
KPÖ und Bierpartei haben es nicht reingeschafft. Ja, kein Bier.
Und ja, also das ist so die Ausgangslage gewesen, Ende September.
Und dann gab es Gesprächsrunden, die unser Bundespräsident Alexander Van der
Bellen, der sympathische Kettenraucher,
immer führt und wo er versucht auszuloten, wie es denn steht und wem man einen
Regierungsbildungsauftrag geben kann.
Also in Österreich ist auf Bundesebene kein Automatismus, sondern der Bundespräsident
hat hier eigentlich eine moderierende Rolle.
Das nimmt er auch teilweise wahr.
Am Ende ist es aber auch so, wenn jetzt jemand kommt, der sagt,
ich habe eine Mehrheit im Nationalrat hinter mir, mach mich zum Kanzler,
kann er schwer Nein sagen.
So weit ist es aber nie gekommen, weil Herbert Kickl, der Wahlgewinner,
da war schon sehr schnell klar, mit dem will eigentlich niemand verhandeln Die
ÖVP ist bei ihrer Linie geblieben,
nicht mit dieser FPÖ unter diesem Parteiobmann Herbert Kickl,
der wirklich keinerlei Abgrenzung nach rechts vornimmt, eher im Gegenteil,
Und dann war es so, dass Herbert Kickl eben da von allen eigentlich ausgeschlossen
wurde und insofern auch er gar nicht den Auftrag zur Regierungsbildung bekommen hat.
Der ging an die ÖVP unter dem damaligen Kanzler Nehammer und da gab es dann
Gespräche mit der Sozialdemokratie und den Liberalen, mit der SPÖ und den Neos also,
die über mehrere Monate gelaufen sind, aber dann Anfang Jänner scheiterten,
als die Neos zuerst den Tisch verlassen haben und meinten, So,
die Reformen, die wir eigentlich bräuchten oder gerne hätten,
die sind hier nicht machbar und damit stehen wir auf und sagen sozusagen unsere
Beteiligung in dieser Regierung, blasen wir ab.
Das hat mich sehr an die FDP erinnert, weil es wirklich ein sehr eigennütziges.
Lieber nicht regieren als falsch regieren.
Genau. Also auch so dieses, das könnte ja schwierig werden, da müssten wir vielleicht
auch mal Kompromisse machen, da müssten wir vielleicht wirklich mal Verantwortung
übernehmen und dazu waren die Liberalen nicht bereit.
Also meiner Leser hat es da eine sehr harte, weil auch in allen Gesprächen eher
ich den Eindruck hatte, man ist sich einfach nicht der Konsequenz bewusst gewesen, was das auslöst.
Weil mit dem Aufstehen der Liberalen hat dann einen Tag später auch die ÖVP
den Verhandlungstisch verlassen und gemeint ja nur mit den Sozialdemokraten,
das wollen wir uns nicht antun.
Es wäre mathematisch möglich gewesen mit einem einzigen Mandatüberhang,
dass man eine Regierung bildet, was auch sehr fragil ist, muss man dazu sagen.
Also in Österreich häufiger als, also in Deutschland gab es das schon.
Na, bei uns wäre es wirklich problematisch, weil wenn da mal jemand krank ist,
wenn es jemand nicht zur Abstimmung schafft, dann könntest du theoretisch diese Regierung sprengen.
Also sobald es eine Mehrheit im Nationalrat gegen diese Regierung gibt,
könntest du mit Misstrauensantrag dieser Regierung aus dem Amt entheben.
Und deswegen ist es wichtig, dass die Regierung ihre Mehrheit im Nationalrat
zu jeder Zeit aufrechterhält.
Und deswegen verstehe ich, dass man da nicht nur mit einer hauchdünnen Zweierkoalition,
sondern gleich mit einem Dreierbündnis gestartet ist.
Aber ja, all das war passé und es war dann relativ schnell klar,
dass diese Dreier-Koalition zu dem Zeitpunkt Anfang Jänner nichts wird und daraufhin
hat auch Bundeskanzler und ÖVP-Chef Nehammer seinen Rücktritt aus beiden Ämtern
Parteichef und Kanzler angekündigt.
Der ist auch zurückgetreten inzwischen und daraufhin hat sein Stellvertreter,
Herr Stocker, das Amt des Parteichefs
übernommen und ist in Koalitionsverhandlungen mit der FPÖ angetreten.
Ist der jetzt auch Kanzler?
Nein, Kanzler ist der Herr Schallenberg, unser ehemaliger Außenminister,
Adelsgeschlecht, Diplomatensohn und der war davor schon mal interimistisch Kanzler.
Ja, der ist gut im Nichtstun und professionell dabei ausschauen.
Ja, professionelles Nichtstun, das ist eine vollkommen unterschätzte Fähigkeit.
Die Tagespresse hatte einen wunderschönen Artikel über ihn, weil er dann wirklich
so ewig lange in diesem Interregnum so formal Kanzler war und er so,
etwas Sinnvolles mit der Zeit anfangen, Schallenberg lernen, stricken. So ungefähr.
Tagespresse ist wie Pastian, ne?
Sehr zu empfehlen, besonders in Zeiten der Regierungskrise ist die Tagespresse
wirklich eine sehr große homologische Bereicherung.
Ja, also ohne Satire und ohne Luftbuch-Netzpolitik.
Auf jeden Fall, wie ging es weiter? Ich habe gerade aufgelassen, so beim Cliffhanger.
Also es gab dann einen Regierungsbildungsauftrag an Herbert Kickl.
An jemanden, der davor von allen Parteien als nicht regierungsfähig,
als der kann es einfach nicht, das ist gefährlich für das Land,
für den Rechtsstaat, für die liberale Demokratie,
wenn der an die Macht kommt.
Und für die EU.
Ja, auch für die Ukraine. Und dann wurde verhandelt, den Jänner hindurch,
bis dann, jetzt ist wegen dem ganzen hier herumreisen in Asien,
bei der Timeline ein bisschen fuzzy.
Das war aber noch, als ich in Österreich war, dass diese Gespräche gescheitert
sind, sprich wir sind wahrscheinlich da jetzt so im Februar, dass...
Ein paar Sachen relativ gleichzeitig passiert sind.
Es war ein Samstag, als ein 230-seitiges Protokoll der Koalitionsverhandlungen
seinen Weg an die Medien gefunden hat.
Und innerhalb kürzester Zeit dann auch auf unseren Tisch.
Wir haben auch so richtig mit Netzpolitik.orgs-Logo nicht nur darüber berichtet,
sondern gleich auch das Dokument veröffentlicht mit einer Einordnung.
Und diese über 200 Seiten haben es in sich.
Also um einen groben Einblick zu geben, natürlich ist so die gesamte Frage,
wie sich Österreich zu Russland verhält, ein zentrales Thema und hier gab es keine Einigung,
Sanktionen gegen Russland überhaupt offiziell zu erhalten oder auch irgendeine
Form der Unterstützung für die Ukraine.
Es gab ein Zugehen auf Donald Trump.
Es waren klar wieder so Genderverbote und so Symbolpolitik drinnen.
Es war das komplette Aussetzen der EMRK im Gespräch, also der Europäische Menschenrechtskonvention.
Der Vorrang vom europäischen Recht über nationalen Recht war ein Streitpunkt.
Die FPÖ wollte entgegen aller europäischer Verträge auf einmal nationalem Recht
den Vorrang geben, was nur auf einem Totalkonflikt mit der EU hinauslaufen kann.
Ja, klar.
Es war aus grundleichtlicher Perspektive enorm gefährlich.
Wir haben teilweise Maßnahmen da drin gehabt, wie eine Präventivhaft für Gefährder,
sprich nicht verurteilte Menschen, die noch nicht einmal angekackt sind, sollen ins Gefängnis.
Eine Fußfessel für, Zitat, Risiko-Asylanten.
Es gab Vorstöße der Kriminalisierung von Meinungen, also des Schaffens des neuen
Straftatsbestandes, der sich für illegale Migration ausspricht.
Spricht eine humanitäre Meinung in Migrationsfragen zu haben,
wäre dann eine Straftat.
Also es waren so symbolische Sachen wie die EU-Fahnen auf allen Amtsgebäuden
zu entfernen, was natürlich auch einfach nur so eine bewusste Provokation.
Besondere Aufmerksamkeit hat der Bereich innerer Sicherheit verdient.
Man wollte Geheimdienstkontrolle massiv abbauen, Überwachungskompetenzen ausbauen.
Das ist jetzt keine Überraschung.
Aber gerade in dem Bereich Geheimdienste hat man auch wirklich so mit Flexiklauseln
argumentiert zwischen Polizei und Geheimdienst.
Sozusagen das Trennungsgebot bewusst außer Kraft setzen und nachrichtendienstliche
und polizeiliche Arbeit miteinander vermengen.
In diesem Papier gibt es auch relativ viele netzpolitische Maßnahmen,
Ausbau von Wiederüberwachung, von Gesichtserkennung,
Handyauswertung von Geflüchteten, also auch eine Verpflichtung,
das eigene Smartphone vorzulegen, um überhaupt einen Asylantrag stellen zu können.
Smartboard, also alle Formen von technologischer Aufrüstung an Grenzen,
auch das Schaffen von Straftatbeständen, irgendwelche Grenzen zu überwinden,
auch technische Maßnahmen in denen.
Es gab ein paar Punkte, wo man sagen muss, dass die FPÖ der ÖVP Überwachungsforderungen
nicht durchgehen hat lassen, insbesondere der Bereich Staatstrojaner, Bundestrojaner.
Wollte die ÖVP, hat die FPÖ nicht mitgestimmt.
Auch eine Identifizierungspflicht im Internet, dass man sich registrieren muss,
bevor man in irgendwelchen Online-Foren posten kann.
Wollte die ÖVP, hat die FPÖ nicht mitgemacht.
Dieser ganze Bereich Hass im Netz, da haben uns eben keine Verbesserungen erwartet,
aber man wollte sogar den Digital
Services Act zurücknehmen und hatte hier auch Maßnahmen diskutiert,
sozusagen dieses EU-Gesetz, was ja direkt anwendbar ist, in Österreich außer Kraft zu setzen,
was auch rechtlich gar nicht geht.
Ja, was dann ID Austria, EIDAS und digitalen Euro und Verwaltungsdigitalisierung
betrifft, gab es ein paar gute Sachen sogar.
Und auch was die Sicherheit und die Umsetzung von den Zweirechtlinien betrifft.
Aber das sind alles eher so Detailpunkte, wo ich mich zwar aus einer sachlichen
Ebene freue, dass es jetzt irgendwie das Beispiel gibt. Gut,
da gab es eine Einigung, aber das ist natürlich in der Gesamtbetrachtung, muss das hintanstehen.
Die Frage, an der sich diese Verhandlungen aber am Ende gespießt haben,
waren nicht die vielen, vielen Punkte, die dann auch auf Rot waren,
wo man uneinig war, sondern die Frage des Innenministeriums und der Postenverteilung.
Und das hat eine Geschichte in Österreich.
War ja schon mal Innenminister und wurde dieses Amtes enthoben,
weil er sich so dermaßen heftig aufgeführt
hat, auch ja eine Razzia im Inlandsgeheimdienst durchgeführt hat.
Darüber haben wir auch schon einmal berichtet, weil insbesondere das Extremismusreferat
sehr genau durchsucht wurde, also dort, wo die Rechtsextreme beobachtet werden.
Und die ÖVP war wirklich zu vielen bereit, aber wollte halt nicht das Innenministerium aufgeben.
Und keine der beiden Parteien wollten es aber bei der anderen Partei sehen und
sahen es natürlich als rechtsgerichtete, sicherheitsfokussierte Partei,
auch als Kernkompetenz von sich selbst.
Ja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Am Ende sind diese Verhandlungen gescheitert.
Das hat mehrere Tage gedauert, aber dann war irgendwann klar,
die kommen immer zusammen.
Ja, und jetzt sind wir wieder bei Square One.
Jetzt verhandeln wieder ÖVP, SPÖ und Liberale.
Das heißt, wir sind wieder bei einer potenziellen Hello Kitty-Koalition.
Man will diesmal flotter vorankommen, vielleicht im März schon Angelobung.
Das Ganze muss auch noch, also sollte es ein Ergebnis geben,
müsste es durch die Mitgliederversammlungen von den Liberalen,
ich glaube nur den Liberalen, auch noch bestätigt werden, dieses Ergebnis,
bevor man in diese Regierung eintreten kann.
Aber es war, man kann sagen, so für alle auch eine Schrecksituation,
mal auf schwarz und weiß zu lesen,
wie schlimm es hätte werden können und ich glaube das war so ein bisschen ein
Weckruf für die demokratischen Parteien zu sagen okay, dann sind unsere Unterschiede
vielleicht eh nicht so groß, lass es uns nochmal probieren,
Das ist jetzt die optimistische Lesart. Schauen wir, ob sie es zusammenbringen.
Man muss auch dazu sagen, ich glaube, dass dieser Leak passiert ist, war auch kein Zufall.
Also die ÖVP, also in den Metadaten ist dieses Dokument eigentlich einer Person der FPÖ zuzuordnen.
Aber ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass die Interessen eher bei der ÖVP gelegen sind,
das Ganze in die Luft gehen zu lassen.
Wenn man einfach gesehen hat, okay gut, das würde unsere Reputation und auch
unser Bild als Europapartei, was man schon über Jahrzehnte hochgehalten hat,
einfach so nachhaltig zerstören, das können wir uns selber nicht antun.
Man muss auch sagen, dass die FPÖ, also gerade Herbert Kickl,
sehr Donald-Trump-Strategie gefahren hat.
Also das war eine Verhandlung mit, ich will 180 Prozent und wenn du ganz hart
verhandelst mit mir, dann gehe ich runter auf 150 Prozent.
Aber man könnte ihm es zutrauen, dass er wirklich gesagt hat,
ich will das so machen wie Viktor Orban.
Ich will nicht mit 30 Prozent mitregieren. Ich pokere hoch und will dann auf
die 40, 50 Prozent kommen und das alleine so durchziehen.
Ich würde kurz anmerken, dass es nicht die Trumpsche Verhandlungsstrategie ist,
sondern die Putinsche Verhandlungsstrategie.
So gehen die Russen in Verhandlungen rein und Trump hätte das glaube ich ganz
gerne und probiert das jetzt auch irgendwie, aber bisher waren die Ergebnisse eher nicht so.
Also wenn du dir mal anschaust, wie der erste Aufschlag für seine Tarifandrohung
für Kanada und Mexiko gelaufen sind, also da ist er definitiv nicht mit 150% rausgegangen.
Ja, da hast du recht.
Aber es stimmt schon, auch diese Doge-Nummer,
wir wollen nicht so viel über USA reden, aber das ist natürlich für die rechtsgerichteten
Parteien sozusagen jetzt so ein bisschen so eine Inspiration.
Oh ja, lass uns einfach mal den ganzen Staat komplett zerschlagen,
lass uns doch mal alle Sicherheitsmechanismen, mit denen wir jetzt unsere Demokratie
aufrecht gehalten haben, lass uns die dann einfach mal zerstören.
Weil dann werden wir nicht mehr so sehr kontrolliert und wir können unsere mafiästen
Bestrebungen hier ran machen. Weil sagen wir mal, wie es ist.
Also ich meine, das ist halt einfach rechtsgerichtet Faschismus.
Ja, das sind so aufgeladene Begriffe. Am Ende ist das einfach mafiös.
Das sind einfach Leute, die wollen irgendwie diesen Staat berauben.
Die wollen sich irgendwie selber die Kohle und die Macht zuschieben und kein
anderes Interesse existiert da.
Und das sind keine Ideologien, keine Überzeugungen, denen sind halt einfach
die anderen Leute vollkommen egal und da sich die meisten Leute halt immer irgendwie.
Weil der Rassismus so stark ist, sind halt Ausländer und alle damit verbundenen
Themen halt immer das Thema Nummer eins, weil da regen sich immer alle total
drüber auf und dann wird irgendwie die starke Partei,
die angeblich starke Partei gewählt,
weil es muss ja mal was geschehen und die anderen machen ja nichts.
Es ist immer derselbe Scheißdreck, aber am Ende wählst du die Mafia und das
ist mit Trump so, das ist mit Putin so, das ist mit der FPÖ so, das ist mit der AfD so.
Wenn du schaust, wer sie finanziert, da ist das große Geld, die kriegen irgendwie
Millionen Spenden, da sind dann irgendwelche dicken Businesses,
die dann eben sozusagen auch gleich ins Mafiaspiel mit einsteigen und sagen,
ah ist klar, wir geben euch jetzt hier ein bisschen Kohle, dafür wollen wir
dann aber auch hintenrum wieder sparen. am Ende sind das einfach Business Deals.
So, muss man auch mal so sehen.
Faschism is the merger of the companies with the state.
Ja, genau, das ist der Punkt und das war schon immer so und das muss man einfach
den Leuten nochmal klar machen, dass hier überhaupt gar keine Interessen von
Kleinen sind und schon gar nicht von allen.
Wir müssen jetzt die Kurve kratzen und von diesem tiefen Politikloch in das wir uns gegraben haben.
Ja, was brauchst du? Eine Überleitung?
Ja, gib mir eine Überleitung.
Ja. Der Kampf für die Freiheit geht aber weiter.
Ja, ich wollte ja noch berichten über Netznatalität.
Ja, dein Lieblingsthema, da machst du auch einen Vortrag morgen drüber, habe ich gehört.
Genau, genau. Und in der letzten Sendung hatte ich ja schon angekündigt,
dass wir am 38 C3 was vorstellen werden.
Das taten wir auch und ihr findet es auf netzbremse.de.
Worum handelt es sich? Es ist ein gemeinsames Projekt der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte
mit dem Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband, Professorin Barbara von Schewig von
der Stanford Law School und Epicenter Works.
Wir vier klagen gegen die Deutsche Telekom wegen deren Netzneutralitätsverletzungen
im Bereich der Zusammenschaltung.
Es ist ein altbekanntes Problem in Deutschland, dass die Deutsche Telekom nur
dann Daten in ihr Netz lässt, wenn sie dafür auch Geld bekommt,
mittelbar oder unmittelbar.
Es führt zu nichts anderem aus einer bezahlten Überholspur und einer Einschränkung
der Wahlfreiheit der Kundinnen und Kunden von der Deutschen Telekom.
Und dagegen wollen wir vorgehen mit einer Beschwerde an die Bundesnetzagentur.
Details finden sich auf der Webseite, da ist auch der Vortrag am 38c3 verlinkt.
Und seit wir das vorgestellt haben, haben wir im Kongress irgendwie noch so
gesagt, ja, meldet euch, wenn ihr helfen wollt.
Bitte tut das aktuell gerade nicht mehr, weil wir haben wirklich sehr,
sehr, sehr viele Zuschriften bekommen, das uns unheimlich freut.
Aber wir kommen nicht mehr hinterher, weil es wirklich so viele Berichte sind
und auch Hilfsangebote.
Wir haben da jetzt zwei, drei Schritte gerade gesetzt, um das schön abzuarbeiten
und uns dann auch nochmal strukturiert da an die Community zu wenden.
Vor allem eben auch, was das Thema Leaks und Messungen betrifft,
kann man sich weiterhin bei uns melden, weil ich glaube, dazu braucht es immer
noch eine größere Anstrengung.
Und ja, dieses Projekt wird auf jeden Fall noch weitergehen.
Und der Schriftsatz wird jetzt gerade noch reviewt von den einzelnen Organisationen,
sodass er dann bald an die Bundesnetzagentur gehen kann und natürlich dadurch
auch veröffentlicht wird.
Und ja, dann könnt ihr euch freuen, dass es noch mehr von uns zu dem Thema geben wird.
Ich will noch nicht zu viel sagen, weil wir wollen irgendwie zuerst mal alles
auf den Tisch legen und dann können wir da gesondert drüber reden.
Aber das ist ein, finde ich, sehr wichtiges Projekt, was natürlich auch im Kontext
der EU-weiten Debatte oder weltweiten Debatte zu Netzgebühren zu sehen ist.
Diese Idee, dass man nur noch in gewisse Teilnetze des Internets Daten leiten
kann, wenn man noch Geld mitschickt, ist brandgefährlich für das globale,
neutrale Netz und darum wird es auch morgen bei dem Projekt,
Pendel gehen, was wir haben.
Überraschend.
Netzbremse.de So, und dann haben wir noch ein bisschen was zu EIDAS.
Ja, das ist nur ganz kurz. Also auch da ist ein kleines Update vonnöten.
Und zwar die Verhandlungen zur EIDAS-Verordnung gehen ja weiter,
auch wenn das eigentliche Gesetz schon im Amtsblatt veröffentlicht ist.
Schon im Mai letzten Jahres ist das passiert. Aber jetzt sind wir in der Phase,
wo Implementing Acts geschrieben werden.
Das sind sowas wie Beipackzettel für Gesetze, die dann nochmal Details festlegen.
Hin und wieder sind das aber auch extrem wichtige Details, gerade bei technischen Gesetzen.
Und EIDAS zählt hier eindeutig dazu.
Also hier wurde schon ein erster Batch an Implementing Acts verabschiedet.
Wir haben uns eingebracht, wir haben relativ viele Dinge noch gerettet und klargestellt
im Sinne von Nutzerrechte, aber es gibt noch ein paar Punkte,
über die aktuell gestritten wird und zwar die Frage der Registrierung von Reliant
Parties, also von Firmen oder Behörden, die was von uns wissen wollen.
Die müssen ja sich bei einer staatlichen Stelle registrieren mit dem Use Case,
den sie haben und den Attributen, die sie über die Wallet abfragen wollen.
Und dann gibt es auch eine Warnung, beziehungsweise in manchen Ländern auch
ein Verbot, wenn du mehr als das abfragst.
Darüber haben wir lange gestritten. Da gab es auch einen großen, offenen Brief.
Das haben wir gewonnen jetzt im letzten Vorschlag. Also nach dem,
was die Kommission zuletzt auf den Tisch gelegt hat, ist dieses Thema gelöst.
Also dann hätten wir wirklich eine saubere Registrierung.
Diese Registry ist auch öffentlich einsehbar und es darf dich nicht irgendeine
Apotheke auf einmal Dinge fragen aus deinem Familienleben, sondern es muss immer
in Hand dieses Use Cases sein und du darfst nicht mehr erfragen von Leuten.
Worüber noch gestritten wird, ist das Thema rechtliche Verpflichtung zu identifizieren.
Es gibt ja alle möglichen Anwendungsfälle für die Wallet.
Wenn du bei einer Bank bist und ein Konto aufmachst, dann musst du dich identifizieren.
Es gibt keine anonymen Konten.
Wenn du bei Facebook dich einloggst, dann darfst du natürlich ein Pseudonym verwenden.
Und die Kommission ist aber nicht der Meinung, dass diese zwei Use Cases sauber zu trennen sind.
Sondern die sagen, ach, wenn das Unternehmen glaubt, es muss identifizieren,
dann soll es das einfach tun können und auch staatliche Identitäten anfragen dürfen.
Das ist begründet mit einer ganz komischen rechtlichen Auffassung,
die einige Leute zum Naserümpfen bringt.
Nämlich es gibt so eine Bestimmung, die sagt, ja wenn du in gewissen Branchen
für deine AGBs die Wallet, die Identifizierung von Leuten machen musst,
dann musst du die Wallet anbieten.
Als einen Weg. Du kannst immer noch einen Pass hintragen, aber die Wallet muss
ein Weg sein, wie du digital dich ausweist.
Und aus dieser Bestimmung in Artikel 5f hat die Kommission aus irgendeinem Grund
das Problem aufgemacht, dass sie sagt, ja, aber dieses Recht,
dass du Pseudonyme verwenden darfst und diese Verpflichtung für Firmen,
Pseudonyme anzunehmen,
die lassen wir einfach weg, die vergessen wir, die setzen wir gar nicht um in Implementing Acts.
Wenn die aufgrund ihres Vertrages glauben, sie müssen dich identifizieren,
dann dürfen sie deine staatlichen Identitätsdaten auch anfragen.
Und das geht eindeutig zu weit. Das würde auch dieses System ad absurdum führen,
weil du hast sehr legitime Use Cases, wo es halt wirklich darum geht,
was mit einem Notar etwas zu tun hast oder mit staatlichen Stellen, E-Government.
Klar, da musst du dich identifizieren. Aber alles, wo diese Wallet eingesetzt
wird, in Wald und Wiesen Internet- oder E-Commerce-Anwendungen,
da hast du keine Identifizierungspflicht und da wäre die auch hochgradig gefährlich.
Überlege dir in sozialen Netzwerken, wie oft dort Anonymität und Pseudonymität
die Voraussetzungen für Meinungsfreiheit sind.
Also die Kommission agiert hier wieder einmal sehr kopflos, aber darüber wird
jetzt gerade gestritten. Wir sind jetzt gerade am 26.
Februar in der letzten inoffiziellen Runde, im März wird dann abgestimmt.
Und ja, ein weiteres letztes Thema, was hier auch gerade noch am Tableau ist,
sind Unique Identifier.
Das wundert mich sehr, dass wir darüber jetzt noch einmal streiten müssen,
weil ich erinnere mich noch, im Juni 2023 hat das Europaparlament auf den Tisch
gehauen und gesagt, nein, machen wir nicht.
Und es gab eigentlich eine Einigung im Trilog.
Also Unique Identifier für Personen.
Genau, eine Seriennummer für jeden Menschen von Geburt an. Diese eindeutige
dauerhafte Personenkennung ist in Deutschland aufgrund höchstrichtlicher Urteile illegal.
In Österreich und in den Niederlanden wäre sie das auch.
Das ist kritisch zu sehen, deswegen hat das Europaparlament hier eine rote Linie
gesetzt, die so ausschaut.
Diese eindeutigen Personenkennzeichen, die darf es nicht geben.
Es darf ein Matching von Identitäten geben, aber nur für den öffentlichen Sektor
in grenzüberschreitenden Fällen.
Und das will die Kommission jetzt aber ausbauen und sagen, na,
wir machen doch eindeutige Identifikatoren und die dürfen auch für die Privatwirtschaft
verwendet werden, in den Fällen, wo es eine rechtliche Verpflichtung gibt,
Kunden oder User zu identifizieren.
Und dazu gibt es inzwischen auch schon ein Naserümpfen aus dem Europaparlament.
Die Europaabgeordnete, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es schon öffentlich ist und ob
ich den Namen sagen soll.
Ich danke an dieser Stelle einfach dem Büro von Abgeordneter Birgit Zippel und
anderen Sozialdemokratinnen in dem Thema, die dazu gearbeitet haben und glaube
ich auch schon parlamentarische Anfragen dazu gestellt haben.
Das finde ich sehr gut, weil hier muss das Parlament wirklich auf den Deal pochen,
der im Trilog mit ihm geschlossen wurde.
Ansonsten, wozu machen wir den ganzen Scheiß, wenn die Gesetze nachher eh nicht eingehalten werden?
Alright.
Dann das aller, aller, allerletzte Thema und dann bin ich auch still.
Die MEP.eu, diese freie Software, ein Kampagnen-Tool fürs Europaparlament,
haben wir schon mehrmals in der Sendung besprochen.
Dazu muss nicht mehr gesagt werden, außer es ist jetzt fertig und der komplette
Source-Code ist auf GitHub verfügbar.
Wir verlinken den in den Shownotes und das ist hoffentlich etwas,
das noch viele Leute bei den nächsten Kämpfen im Plenum des Europaparlaments
dann unterstützen kann.
Auf dem Account vom AK Vorrat, interessanterweise.
Ja, wir waren ja mal der AK Vorrat und auf GitHub kann man die Username nicht ändern.
Ah, echt, kann man nicht?
Ich glaube nicht. Ich weiß es nicht. Die Kommentare werden es uns sagen.
Ah.
Okay. Da habe ich drüber nachgedacht.
Verstehe. Ist aber hier als Epicenter Works ausgeschrieben.
Heißt bloß in der URL AK Vorrat. Verstehe. Okay, gut, ja, alles klar.
Ist jetzt Open Source. Sehr schön. Ist eine Python Software,
wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Richtig? Genau.
Okay. Cool. Na dann sind wir durch hier mit der Sendung.
Das war's hier von uns aus Taiwan. Ganz exklusiv.
Mit Blick über die moderne Welt hier aus unserem Hotelzimmer heraus. Ganz opulent.
Und ja, wir hoffen, das war was für euch.
Und schauen wir mal, wie es weiter geht mit der nächsten Sendung. Tschüss und bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.